Salut à tous et à toutes,
Aujourd’hui, pour Brut, je vous emmène en Alabama
mais c’est clairement pas pour visiter.
Ne laisse pas ces brutes déchiqueter votre enfant.
Ce sont des monstres. Ils s'en foutent.
Cet État est en guerre contre l’avortement dans l'Amérique misogyne de Trump.
Là-bas, les femmes se rebellent et notamment les victimes de viols.
En 2017, j’ai été violée par un collègue…
Le jour de mon avortement, des manifestants étaient là, devant la clinique.
Ne commets pas un meurtre, les meurtriers ne connaîtront jamais le paradis.
Vous êtes un assassin, vous irez en enfer,
comment pouvez-vous tuer un bébé ?
C’est un lieu de mort.
Ne faites pas confiance à cette clinique.
Faites confiance au seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Cette interdiction a été proposée
pour satisfaire les ultra-conservateurs évangéliques.
Maintenant, pour la première fois,
les États-Unis ont un président pro-life…
C’est plutôt bien.
Des images et des interviews d'extrémistes anti-avortement
vous en avez sûrement déjà vu partout.
Mais avec Brut,
on a choisi de donner d’abord la parole au camp d’en face :
des Américaines debout,
des brigades de femmes qui défendent leur droit à disposer de leurs corps, librement.
Tant qu’il y aura des gens devant cette clinique
sur ce trottoir qui les traitent comme ça,
je serai là.
Celles et ceux qui, comme cette femme,
défendent le droit à l’IVG aux États-Unis on ne les appelle pas les pro-avortement,
on les appelle les \"pro-choice\" :
c’est-à-dire qu’ils sont pour le droit de choisir ou pas d’avoir recours à une IVG.
En face, ils se font appeler les \"pro-life\" :
des religieux chrétiens qui harcèlent celles qui souhaitent avoir recours à l’IVG
et diffusent ça en direct sur les réseaux sociaux.
Regardez, ça se passe à Montgomery,
devant l’une des 2 dernières cliniques qui pratiquent l’avortement en Alabama.
5h du matin,
7 ou 8 femmes sont déjà là pour tuer leurs bébés.
Jésus-Christ est notre seigneur.
Bienvenue devant les portes de l’enfer.
Mon ami, regarde Jésus aujourd’hui,
fais confiance au seigneur, il aime ton enfant.
Dieu te connaît, c’est lui qui t’a fait.
Salut ma chérie,
on va marcher ensemble, t’inquiète pas.
Ignore ces idiots et tout ira bien.
On utilise nos parapluies pour cacher les patientes
face aux manifestants…
On les met comme ça
pour empêcher qu’ils les prennent en photo
et qu’ils filment, sinon ils violent leur vie privée.
Soumets toi à Jésus aujourd’hui.
On a eu le cas d’une étudiante de l’université d’Alabama,
elle a été exclue de son établissement,
on lui a même retiré sa bourse.
C’est vraiment grave d’être vu devant cette clinique
et reconnu sur Facebook, Twitter, Instagram.
Certaines femmes risquent d’être blessées, même d’être tuées…
Si leur famille, leur église sont anti-avortement,
si leur patron est anti-IVG, elles peuvent perdre leur boulot.
Elles se retrouvent exclues de la communauté.
Tout ça à cause de l’image de l’avortement dans l’État d’Alabama.
J’utilise ma caméra comme vous,
c’est pour montrer aux autres chrétiens de Montgomery ce qu’il se passe ici.
Regardez ce qu’ils font sous le regard de Jésus.
Je suis pas là pour afficher ces femmes,
mais je vais vous dire, j’ai aucun problème à montrer leurs visages.
Ces femmes, je les aime mais elles commettent un crime.
Un meurtre.
En fait, je les montre au monde tout comme vous.
Madame, je vous aime aujourd’hui.
Ecoutez-moi, j’ai juste un message.
Vous avez magnifiquement conçu ce bébé.
Vous avez toute votre vie devant vous, votre carrière
mais vous pouvez avoir tout ça même avec un bébé.
Madame, tournez vous vers Jésus, ne regardez pas la clinique.
Choisissez la vie,
25 bébés sont tués chaque semaine…
C'est une classe de maternelle exterminée,
tout le monde s'inquiète des armes à feu
mais qui parle de ces meurtres d’innocents chaque semaine ?
Aujourd’hui je joins ma foi avec les croyants
et je prie pour ne jamais me taire
et toujours me battre aux côtés des pro-life.
Voilà le décor.
L’Alabama est l’un des État les plus conservateurs du pays
mais aussi l’un des moins éduqués et des plus pauvres…
À la sortie de la clinique, nous avons rencontré cette mère célibataire
qui vient de se faire avorter.
Elle a souhaité gardé l’anonymat,
elle a deux enfants à charge
et deux boulots pour s’en sortir.
Pour elle, l’avortement est un choix,
celui de ne pas mettre au monde un enfant qu’elle ne pourra pas assumer.
Mon choix est mon choix, même si ça te plaît pas.
Ils peuvent crier autant qu’ils veulent et me dire que je vais mourir et brûler en enfer,
que je dois me soucier de cet enfant.
Mais c’est ce que j’ai fait,
et c’est pour ça que j’ai fait ce choix car je ne peux pas l’assumer.
Vous êtes pro-vie, anti avortement, OK
mais on fait quoi de ce bébé une fois qu’il est né ?
Vous n’allez pas vous occuper de cet enfant.
Ils disent : \"Nous pouvons vous aider.\" Mais comment ?
Ce sont eux qui vont payer mes soins médicaux,
payer son éducation…
Non, ils veulent juste que je ne rentre pas dans cette clinique et que je n’avorte pas.
Mais après ça, une fois qu’il est né, ils n'en ont rien à foutre du futur de ce gamin.
En Alabama, le mouvement anti-avortement est déjà allé beaucoup plus loin
1570894901720
que des coups de pression et des insultes.
Des médecins qui pratiquaient l’avortement y ont déjà été assassinés.
Le type est apparu tout d’un coup,
il s’est jeté sur le docteur et a tiré à bout portant.
Le premier médecin à avoir été tué par un manifestant anti-avortement
travaillait dans notre clinique.
L'Alabama a une histoire marqué par la violence envers ceux qui pratiquent l’IVG.
Dans notre histoire, il y a toujours eu cette violence
et elle peut ressurgir à tout moment.
On ne sait jamais ce qu’il peut arriver.
Malheureusement, ces anti-IVG sont en train de gagner la bataille politique.
Le Sénat d’Alabama a voté en mai 2019
une loi interdisant les interruptions de grossesse,
et ce, même en cas de viol ou d’inceste.
Et devinez quoi,
ce vote a été adopté grâce aux voix de 25 sénateurs,
tous des hommes, tous blancs, tous républicains.
Vous savez ce que ça fait d’être violée ?
- Non, je ne sais pas.
- Vous savez ce que cela fait d’être abusée par un proche ?
- Sur moi, je ne sais pas madame.
- Oui, sur vous.
Donc enlevez ce choix à une victime qui a vécu un tel traumatisme…
La laisser seule avec le résidu de ce viol…
Pourquoi ne laissez-vous pas le choix à ces femmes de pouvoir avorter après de telles horreurs ?
Sénateur, vous avez une petite fille ?
- Sénateur, il ne s’agit pas de ma famille.
- Je pose juste une question.
Laissez-moi demander à tous ceux qui ont une petite fille.
Fermez vos yeux quelques secondes.
Vous venez de dire à mon enfant chérie,
ma petite fille adorée,
que tu peux être violée par un de tes oncles,
de tes cousins ou n’importe qui d'autre,
tomber enceinte,
et tu devras t’occuper de cette enfant selon la loi d’Alabama.
C’est important qu’il n'y ait pas d’exception en cas de viol ou d’inceste
car cela ne serait pas cohérent si la loi considère
que le fœtus est un être vivant.
On utilise la définition du code pénal
qui existe déjà en matière d’homicide et de meurtre.
Si vous tuez une femme enceinte de 2 ou 3 mois,
vous serez inculpé d’un double meurtre.
Donc logiquement,
si vous ôtez la vie de cet enfant lors d’un avortement,
eh bien c’est un meurtre.
Aujourd'hui, on a encore tenu une promesse.
Mon administration a proposé de nouvelles règles pour interdire
tout financement public vers les cliniques qui pratiquent l’avortement.
Pour la première fois,
les États-Unis ont un président pro-life, un vice-président pro-life,
une Chambre des représentants pro-life, et 25 États républicains pro-life.
C’est plutôt pas mal.
Trump, il s’agite beaucoup,
il fait beaucoup de bruit.
Mais les gens qui l’entourent, qui prennent les décisions,
ils font un super boulot.
Et je les soutiens.
Comme par exemple ses dernières nominations à la Cour suprême.
La Cour suprême, c’est quoi ?
C’est la plus haute cour de justice américaine
où les \"pro life\" sont désormais majoritaires.
La loi votée en Alabama
a immédiatement été attaquée en justice
par les défenseurs des droits civiques.
Désormais, c'est aux juges de la Cour suprême
de dire dans les prochains mois si oui ou non
la loi interdisant l’avortement en Alabama est légale.
Heureusement, pour le moment
les femmes ont encore le droit d’avorter en Alabama.
Certaines ont décidé de prendre la parole
pour dénoncer cette loi et raconter leur histoire.
C’est le cas de Samantha Blakely,
elle a été violée par son collègue il y a deux ans et a dû se faire avorter.
Les gens ne comprennent pas ce qu’il se passe dans ton corps
lorsque tu tombes enceinte.
Ton corps change et tu y penses constamment.
J’étais malade,
je me sentais si mal
et je ne pouvais pas gérer ça pendant 9 mois.
C’était juste impossible.
Je n’ai pas parlé de mon viol et de mon avortement
à beaucoup de personnes
parce que j’avais peur du regard des autres
et d’être stigmatisée pour ce qui m’était arrivé.
Ici, parfois, les gens ne te croient pas lorsque tu dis que tu as été violée.
Les gens pensent qu’il n’y a aucune bonne raison pour se faire avorter
Des personnes disent que c’est un retour à l'âge de pierre
et que l’on va dans le mauvais sens.
Je pense que c’est une manière de contrôler les femmes,
poussée par les ultra-conservateurs.
C’est une question qui me taraude :
Dois-je rester en Alabama pour améliorer les choses
ou bien dois-je fuir ?
J’ai l’impression de vivre mon traumatisme de nouveau
parce que je me sens obligée de le raconter aux sénateurs.
Même en public, les gens connaissent désormais mon histoire.
Mais c’est important que les gens sachent
à quel point cela a fait du mal à des gens comme moi
et aux habitants d’Alabama.